e
want
e e
there's always something here as you all
know uh before we get started with this
executive session can I ask everybody to
please rise for the
pledge to flag of the United States
ofer
Nation individual liy and justice for
all thank you very
much and the day we've all been waiting
for when we tackle the last four bills
of this
bium so without further Ado um I'll open
up the executive session on Senate Bill
510 and the chair
recognizes representative Coker for a
motion uh thank you Mr chairman um so
I'd like to to make a motion to
introduce Amendment uh
192 if I can stop you need a motion of
not to pass first oh okay so uh
itl not to pass you're making a motion
of ought to pass correct oh sorry ought
to pass okay sorry so we've got a motion
about the P
see it's gonna be one of those gonna be
one of those mornings so
let's Okay so we have a motion of to
pass on Senate Bill 510 is there a
second seconded by representative St
Clair I saw him first uh this uh this
bill with an notop pass is open to
further Amendment she I recognizes
representative Kooker all right the
order of operations is important um so
I'd like to put an amendment uh 2024
19258 to uh Senate Bill
510 okay represent ker moves uh
Amendment 1925 is there a second second
second by representative St Clair again
I care to speak to the amendment yes sir
thank you Mr chairman so this amendment
for uh Senate Bill 510 adds on um House
Bill 1391 which is the um inspection
Bill about having new vehicles inspected
every other year um so we've already
talked about that a lot so I don't think
I need to go into that anymore and it
also adds on um House Bill 16 um was it
1638 which uh basically just some um it
it's some reforms to the inspection um
process and both of these I think we
unanimous unanimously uh brought up 1638
and it went on consent
and um so you know we've already looked
at the policy on this and adding um
these two bills to to 510 you know 510
is going to be good for the automotive
industry and adding these two inspection
bills to it it's going to be good for
the consumers so I think everybody
wins thank you for that and for the
record at a
1637 if you are correct that did come
out of this committee unanimous we were
split on the first year exemption 1291
but they are both house positions
anybody else for from the committee on
the amendment
rep representative rmo I just wanted to
clarify representative Koker the you
said every other year you mean not the
first year you don't need to have an
inspection for the first year of a new
vehicle correct yes sorry first
year yeah and the house rules dictate
how we do this the language in the
amendment is identical to what was
passed out of this committee uh no
changes can be made at this point um
anybody
else seeing none uh I'm going to ask the
clerk to call the role on the amendment
uh adoption of the amendment 1 19 25h
whenever she's
ready Vice chairman Gorski yes
representative Smith yes clerk votes yes
representative Hill yes representative
dumes yes representative foot yes
representative C yes representative
Coker yes representative Sykes yes
representative Rich yes representative
Sinclair yes representative
rang yes represent
Rambo yes representative Au yes
representative nav yes representative
Lon yes representative Calabro yes
representative Johnson yes and chairman
Walsh yes okay 19 to
zero no so our our amendment is adopted
so so now the motion on the floor is
ought to pass as amended on Senate Bill
510 any thoughts or comments from
anybody on the committee up
SES so as you all just witnessed I did
vote for the amendment because it has
some parts that we worked really hard on
um that I'm happy to see go back in
which is the the second part of the
amendment which deals with some of the
obvious disconnects between uh our
citizens and what they experience at the
the dealers and like for instance
cracked uh
uh red light uh back backup lights and
so on um so I I'm very much in favor of
that and that was why I voted for the
amendment however I am opposed to the
one-year uh inspections by uh allowing
new vehicles to not be inspected by the
first year I have a lot of serious
concerns about that um I know that we
will
hear uh while that there's no connection
between inspections and uh crashes well
it's the data is incomplete there's no
actual real data it's trying to prove a
negative which I think is really
Impossible on top of that many vehicles
fail inspection
initially but then the dealer offers to
fix the the slight problem and pass the
vehicle that happened to my own personal
vehicle just two days ago brought it to
the garage to have a recall done they
said we can do your inspections at the
same time they found a minor problem
that would cause it to fail but they
fixed it and my vehicle passed
inspection so I know this to be um very
much something that happens so I
understand that we are trying to find
um ways to make it better for the
motoring public I do not feel that the
second the first half of the amendment
does that and in fact in my mind it
makes people less safe and is a bad
Public Safety uh position to take
consequently I'd be voting against the
uh a motion of ought to pass as
amended thank you anybody
else
nobody well I representative Coker thank
you Mr chairman so I'd like to you know
kind of an observation I have when the
data is hard to get and it it doesn't
push in One Direction or the other It
generally means that there's just not
much data it's not really having an
effect so again like it's it's you know
if if if vehicle inspections actually
correlated with safety and outcomes on
the roadways the data would show that
very easily and the fact that it doesn't
I think uh proves the point that we can
make this change to new vehicle safely
without having an effect on our roadways
thank
you anybody else
I'll just add one more thing I've been
defending this program my whole time in
this house sitting on this committee um
but for the last half a dozen years
we've also been looking at the program
admitting uh that there's probably ways
to make it better and what we have in
the amendment are two common sense
things that I think deserve some
consideration um I think they belong on
a bill as representative Coker said um a
bill that actually helps the dealers and
our Amendment helps our CI
uh I will be supporting this gladly if
nobody else wishes to speak I'll ask the
clerk to call the role the motion is
ought to pass as
amended uh Vice chair Vice chairman
Gorski yes representative Smith yes
clerk votes yes representative Hill yes
representative de yes representative
foot yes representative C yes
representative Coker yes representative
Sykes noes representative Rich yes
representative Sinclair yes
representative run yes representative
Rambo yes representative a yes
representative knob no Representative
pandon no representative Calabro yes
representative Johnson yes and chairman
Walsh yes
16 to
three our recommendation of about to
pass as amend is adop at 16 to three
I'll close the executive session on
Senate Bill
510 uh a few minutes to reset and we
will get into Senate Bill 581
okay I'll open up the executive session
on Cate Bill 581 is there a motion
represented by you thank you Mr chairman
I would like to move uh interim study on
HB
581 uh interm study has been moved by
representative a seconded by
representative Hill care to speak to
your motion sir yes thank you um it was
pointed out to us earlier today that uh
one some wording in the bill might
invalidate the use of a temporary use of
a uh expired driver's license as a
temporary ID uh while you're waiting for
your your full ID to arrive and uh for
that reason that we don't have time to
really deal with making any changes at
this point so just makes sense to
interim study it for
now anybody
else no I Concur and it's uh something
we discovered in communication with the
Secretary of State's office that the
currently the way it is written uh it
does contradict current law on uh the
use for identification purposes of an
expired license so um that and coupled
with the fact that it's a housekeeping
Bill the planet will probably continue
to spin with this going to interim study
so that's what I'll be supporting as
well thank
you seeing nobody else I'll ask the
clerk to call the RO when she's ready
the motion is interim
study Vice chairman Gorski yes
representative Smith yes clerk votes yes
representative Hill yes representative J
yes representative foot yes
representative C yes representative
Coker yes representative Sykes yes
representative Rich yes representative
Sinclair yes representative runs yes
representative Rambo yes representative
AO yes representative Noob yes na I'm
sorry representative pandon yes
representative cabro yes representative
Johnson yes chairman Walsh yes 19 to
zero our recommendation of inter room
studies adopted 19 to zero motion U
consent calendar with no objection
consent it'll be I'll close the
executive session on Senate Bill
581 and next up we'll get into Senate
Bill
501 e
I'll open up the executive session at
Senate Bill
501 which is sorry I should be reading
my titles relative to driver's licenses
for non-citizens residing in New
Hampshire chair recognizes
representative Gorski for motion thank
you Mr chair I wish to move to itl on uh
SP 501 motions in expedient to legislate
is there a second second second by
represent Dain care to speak to your
motion sir I do thank you very much Mr
chairman there are three main reasons
this bill um I cannot support number one
one of the things it does in the very
beginning is just grant changes
non-resident alien to non-citizen just
right off the bat um without any vetting
or anything like that and I have a
concern with that secondly it it talks
about granting cons uh conditional
residence but we never got a definition
of what that
means um and thirdly and probably most
importantly uh one of the lines in the
bill uh really concerns me where it says
once licensed the individual shall be
subject to the same provisions of the
law of as all other
licenses the provision of same
provisions of the law this to me means
that uh a person can use this for voting
and um from election Integrity issue it
really concerns me and as a result of
these reasons I cannot support this
bill anybody else from the
committee
representes so I'll be um opposed to to
the itl motion um the bill is a came
about as a result of the request from
the New Hampshire Division of Motor
Vehicles and it frankly mirrors current
language and practice it's trying to
bring the law
into
um
conformance um we have 55,000 people
driving who are
non citizen residents of New Hampshire
in this state with no no known
documented uh voting problems uh for
those folks um uh we had more people
speak in favor of the bill than we did
against it and for those reasons and
many more I will be uh opposed to the
itl motion so that another motion can be
introduced anybody else from the
committee well seeing none I guess I'll
just mention a couple of things first
I'll start off
um just to get this out of the way it's
been brought to my attention by the
department uh the director of Motor
Vehicles that I may have spoken
inaccurately at our last Hearing in his
absence uh in reviewing the video which
for the first time I can say I really
appreciate having him now um I may have
been a little bit presumptive in one of
the things that I mentioned and that was
that he told me that everybody coming
over through a port adventury received
uh lawful presents um that that's
probably stronger than what he did tell
me what he did mention in a meeting over
at the on Hazen Drive is was an example
of somebody coming across the border
through a Port of Entry who was given a
receipt with lawful presence I don't
want anybody to think that that was a
statement by him saying that it was
everybody because that may not be
accurate since then I'm led to believe
with other sources that is the case but
I just wanted to get that out I don't
want to say things that he said that may
not be completely accurate uh but I will
be voting against this as well um for a
couple of different reasons we one of
them uh one thing that was accurate by
me reviewing the video was I was told
over and over that we're not giving any
licenses to people with pending
Asylum uh hearings or in other words no
pending cases will be given an
authorization a
license then we were told that um if
they do have an employment authorization
document or a temporary work
authorization
that does come with the social security
number and therefore they can get a
license however their their P their case
is still pending um this bill would
would grant that um let me see here what
else do I want to uh the other thing too
this also changes a definition um from
uh where is
it non-resident alien which is still a
legal term to a non-citizen I don't know
if we should be changing our laws
outside of what's a legal definition I
just don't think it's a good idea I
could go on and on on this but I'll be
voting no and I encourage everybody on
the committee to do so anybody else from
the
committee representative Hill uh the one
the one quick comment that I don't make
is um while we're giving licenses for
those that are have Asylum uh hearings
pending there's never been uh to my
understanding an explanation of what
happens if that pending application is
denied um and we have provided that
license so that was one of my concerns
and remains to be so I will be
supporting the itl
motion and we know that the federal
government is issuing temporary work
authorizations we've seen several bills
from this committee over the last few
years looking to close the gap if you
will because generally speaking it's a
year before they get a temporary work
authorization if they're here claiming
Asylum and we've had the bill that
wanted to close that Gap uh up anywhere
up until that year um so it is happening
uh and unfortunately it's happening in
spite of the fact that these people have
not been thoroughly vetted and been
considered legal to stay in the United
States with their claim uh anybody else
from the
committee seeing none motions itl I'll
ask the clerk to call the role when
she's
ready Vice chairman uh Gorski yes
representative Smith yes clerk votes yes
representative Hill yes representative J
yes representative foot yes
representative C yes representative
Coker yes representative
Sykes no representative
Rich representative Sinclair
no representative
Ron no representative Rambo no
Representative auu no
representative
NAB no Representative pondon no
Representative cabro no representative
Johnson no chairman Walsh
yes 10 to
nine in favor yes 10 y yes a
recommendation
our recommendation
of inexpedient to legislate on Senate
Bill 501 is adopted I'll close the
executive session on
501 next up will be Center Bill 358
I'll open up the executive session on
Senate Bill 358 chair recognizes
representative Koker for a motion uh
thank you Mr chairman I make a motion of
a to pass for C Bill
358 um a to pass has been moved is there
a
second seconded by representative Gorski
care to speak to your motion thank you
Mr chairman so uh Senate Bill 358 and it
invalidates the out ofate driver's
license issued specifically to
undocumented immigrants um you know this
is a bill that I it's it's it's it's a
rough it's a rough topic and the way
that I look at this is you know if you
go to the Logan Airport there's people
there literally living in the terminal
running around and those people are here
through a legal immigration process from
what I understand um and the issue that
I have with issuing government IDs to
people who are not here legally who are
not going through the legal immigration
process is by issuing these government
IDs in a way you're condoning illegal
immigration
and we have a crisis and the last thing
in the world you know we're we're having
a hard time getting our hands around the
legal immigration process the last thing
in the world we should be doing right
now is to do anything to encourage more
illegal immigration because that's only
adding to the problems that we have and
it's creating a bigger mess that for an
issue that's already very very hard to
clean up so this isn't about attacking a
community this isn't about going after
people this is about the rule of law and
we have to enforce the laws that we have
and I get that there's some Public
Safety um Arguments for this bill but in
my view we have to to balance that and
there's huge Public Safety implications
with allowing people to run rough shot
over the current laws that we have I
mean we have people that have not been
vetted that are coming through and then
we're issuing IDs to them so this law
doesn't allow profiling it doesn't allow
anything other than if a license is
issued and there's only really a couple
states that do this specifically to
people who are who cannot prove lawful
presence that that Val that license is
not valid in our state um that's all it
does and it's hard to enforce because a
lot of rules are a lot harder to enforce
because we have rights and we want to
protect those rights and but just
because it's hard to enforce doesn't
mean it's a bad policy so uh that's why
I'm going to be voting yes and um I hope
it passes thank
you anybody else from the committee
representative y
hold
on hold on one second we are it's kind
of I've never seen it done we are
actually in the executive session for
this bill let me get some
advice
e
e e
very unusual circumstance we have here
we're in the middle of our executive
session on Senate
Bill
358 I've been requested of the ranking
member to have a caucus they would wish
to have a caucus I know probably what
it's for and I probably know what the
outcome is going to be be but I will do
this we have a
reputation and and and of doing the
right thing and working together in this
committee so I'm going to allow the
caucus so they can have the discussion
I'm going to recess the executive
session on Senate Bill 358 and we'll be
back as soon
as everybody's back in the
room
e
e e
everybody welcome back
um always sometimes I think I'm just way
too nice she recognizes representative
SES thank you Mr chairman uh you're not
too nice from my point of
view
um I move to reconsider House Bill 501
uh motion's been to reconsider 501 might
made by represent Sykes second I'll
speak to my motion representative
seconded by representative be uh this is
no surprise to me just so you all know
uh Mr chairman sure I believe that the
pending motion is on Senate Bill
358 and the reconsideration motion would
only be in order after disposing of 358
so so even though well hold on even
though I recessed
yeah
okay so I'm not saying I'm I'm not
saying that you can't take the motion
just not at this very moment so okay so
I have thank you for that um
representative Smith um we did check
with the clerk and I'm going to ask the
deputy ranking member to read the
clerk's response to our question about
reconsideration and how that
works well I just I thought we would may
maybe it will help clarify things maybe
maybe it will be that uh we we have to I
have to wait a little bit but um if
you've got a communication
representative Val You by all
means I mean because we didn't take this
step
lightly he just said we anyone can move
to reconsider he didn't address whether
we could do it uh while another bill was
recessed okay well then I'm going to I'm
going to take the advice of the Deputy
Speaker of the House in this matter in
terms of the priority and and what which
where we take things up so that being
said GL that you understand where I'm
coming from I will reopen the public I
mean the executive session on Senate
Bill 358 we'll dispose of that and then
move on to any other business um
so we had somebody speak in favor of the
op to pass anybody else wish to speak on
Senate Bill
358 represent St
Clair thank you Mr
chair I don't I don't see how this bill
has anything to do with people being in
this country illegally because these
licenses are issued by other states it
has nothing to do
with anything but that and I can only
envision our Public Safety officials on
the side of the highway with a vehicle
that they've stopped for whatever reason
and then being suspicious even though
they're not supposed to be suspicious of
this person's origin asking for the
driver's license we know of the 19
states that issue these licenses there
are only a few that Mark the licenses
belonging to somebody that is a
non-resident of the country or non
citizen so in their investigation
they're going to have to do which would
probably be timely since we don't have
the records in our in our data
system uh they're going to be tied up on
the side of the road for maybe as long
as 20 30 40 minutes trying to figure
this out and they could be doing a lot
more good for the citizens of this state
uh patrolling our highways for the norm
the numerous violations that can happen
especially drunk driving or answering
other more important calls than to
determine if this
person doesn't meet somebody's criteria
in this state to have the driver's
license issued by another state and I
can only imagine what the potential of
this does I think it's called the
interstate commerce pack that all other
49 states honor uh with regards to our
driver's licenses in this state so
that's just one big concern I have and I
I hope you all will consider that this
is to me nothing but a bizar Bill thank
you anybody else from the committee
representative
a yeah this this bill comes with a lot
of questions um about constitutionality
and um just how it applies to um the
interstate compact do we have the
authority under the Full Faith and
Credit Clause of the Constitution to
invalidate in other states
documentation um how does this
affect we're essentially creating
criminals out of people who have not
committed a criminal offense uh they've
done everything correctly they've proven
that they can drive they've done
everything what a driver's license is
supposed to do proven that they've been
trained and they've been tested and
they've been found safe to be on our
highways um it means they probably have
insurance when otherwise they wouldn't
have um how does this affect um the
interstate commerce clause how does this
affect the the interstate driver's
license compact we have so many
questions on this I don't know how we
can in good
confidence in good faith pass this bill
um with all these questions and
um I guess I'll leave it at that anybody
else from the
committee we already had a turn
representative
rumo um I would add that there was
earlier comment that this bill from
represent Koker is about the rule of law
and I think that's somewhere we agree
just not what that means this is very
much about the rule of law this is about
respecting each State's laws I think
that's something we talk about a lot on
the house floor and the expectation that
New Hampshire's laws will be respected
um and so the idea that we would see fit
to disregard other states laws and as
representative St Clair mentioned run
the risk of that being uh sent back at
us and reciprocated um is is really
surprising to me um and so I would
second all the questions that ref pres
value raised um I'll leave it that
thanks anybody
else represent Gorski thank you Mr
chairman my big concern we're talking
about other states here and we're
assuming that they're fully vetting
these people that we know what their
processes are I I asked a question
during the testimony like what are the
other states and how are they vetting
and we couldn't get an answer to that we
have no idea what these other states do
how long they vet we've had testimony
here in the past that it takes over nine
months to do fully vetting we don't know
what these other states are doing so for
for us to assume that other states are
doing proper full vetting and we should
be accepting that I think is a huge
reach um and I just wanted to throw that
out there
anybody else point of order um I just
heard back from the clerk I asked if we
recess the next bill can we move to
reconsider before bringing before we
bring the recess Bill back up and he
said yes so technically we have a
pending motion that was made before we
took the bill back up that we probably
should dispose of before moving into
this y that information would have been
done I'm not bouncing back and forth um
I I am a man of my word I will not
sneakily close the executive session
after we're done with this and I will
give the opportunity for that motion to
come back for a couple of reasons I'll
explain later but in the meantime we're
going to dispose of
358 anybody else from the committee on
358 represent Smith thank you Mr chair I
just want to address this issue of the
laws of other states um frankly we we
don't care what they are the the
established precedent for all states is
that we set the rules of the road for
our own own State and they're
different for example you can drive in
New Hampshire without insurance I live
on the Vermont border I can drive six
miles from my house and all of a sudden
be guilty of driving without insurance
if I didn't have any and a $1,000 fine
and I believe you can hit criminal level
on that pretty quickly 15y olds in
Florida can get learner permits they
still can't operate in New Hampshire I
mean there there's a myriad of laws that
other states set that we don't recognize
so that that's a wellestablished
precedent we have every right to decide
to do something like this and frankly
it's none of any other State's
business I will add to that too from a
comment I heard earlier that there are
laws strictly governing uh detentions
and how long somebody can be detained on
the side of the road um and also that
only some of the states put markings on
the license not all well then if they
don't then they may not be caught here
if you will but but it will work with
the states that do put a marking on it
so uh not every bill is perfect anybody
else representative a one more quick
comment in Maine you can marry your
first cousin in New Hampshire you cannot
but New Hampshire does not have the
right to invalidate a main marriage or a
main marriage license so it the Full
Faith and Credit Clause of the
Constitution is what supports this and
uh it's it's been tested in many many
times and the interstate compact says
that we're our our rules are close
enough that we will not invalidate
somebody else's driver's license based
on uh any arbitrary laws within the
state that if we recog they recognize
our rules for for granting a driver's
license we recognize their rules for
driving granting a driver's license we
don't automatically invalidate a Florida
Driver's License just because they allow
15 year olds to drive we don't we don't
invalidate U somebody
else's uh
licenses just because we have a
different set of rules and I don't see
how this applies um all the driver's
license is supposed to say is whether
you're you're legally allowed to drive
that's
it that's all I
have okay looks like we do have two
different opinions on this we could keep
going for hours do you have anything
else representative St Clair I'm not
going to stop you either
but I just thank you Mr chair I just um
I just wonder where this goes uh
I'm not sure of the drivers test that
other states give maybe they're not as
good as our our test we give in this
state I mean you can just go on and on
with this and I just think um I can see
walls going up around all of our state
borders uh maybe that's what some people
want to stop anybody from coming into
this state with their driver's license
and when we heard about rapist and
terrorists coming over the border to the
introduction of this bill for our day of
hearings it had absolutely nothing to do
with what we're talking about here yet
these are the I don't know if you call
them a dog whistle or what but the the
stuff that's thrown out there to try to
wrap around why we need these bills and
I just think this is a very bad one
thank you Mr
chair we need these
bills in many people's opinions because
the federal government keeps doing
things that cause us a reason to come up
with Solutions anybody else from the
committee representative and I forget
again that's okay it's collabro collabro
I apologize I'm going to agree with that
last statement there are a lot of things
that need to change with immigration in
order to protect our people better in
this state and I speak to that because I
used to be the person who did addiction
medicine for the homeless in this
state and um nobody wants pentan a out
of this state more than
me um I used to live in a border state
in California and Arizona for years I've
seen this bill
and it killed my
grandmother there were people who were
undocumented immigrants they did not
have a driver's license because
California would not administer it to
them they fled the scene of the accident
my grandmother got a fractured hip and
died within about six months of that
when these laws are enacted they have
consequences I cannot support something
that is only really for two states that
have something on a driver's license
that says this is an undocumented person
and for that reason I won't support
it anybody
else c n the motion is ought to pass on
Senate Bill 358 I'll ask the clerk to
call the role when she's
ready Vice chairman Gorski yes
representative Smith yes clerk votes yes
representative Hill yep representative D
yes representative foot yes
representative C yes representative
Coker yes representative
Sykes no representative Bridge no
Representative cair no representative
rang no representative Rambo no
representative Au no representative NAB
no Representative kandon no
Representative cabro no representative
Johnson no and chairman Walsh yes N9 to
n
days n 10 days nine days 10 days motion
about to pass fails is there a
motion represent
SES thank you Mr chairman I make a
motion of uh
itl represent syes moves in expedient
the legislators there a
second representative V any further
discussion on the bill just I would
speak to my motion um I think we've
heard all the arguments um and I would
urge my colleagues to look at the the
the bigger picture and um I believe
that's enough
said I'll only say this I wish there was
a way to to cover all the states instead
of the ones that put markings just can't
get there yet uh but I still wouldn't
use that as a reason not to do what we
can with nothing else from the committee
I'll ask the clerk to call the role when
she is ready the motion is inexpedient
to
legislate Vice chairman borski no
representative Smith no clerk votes no
representative Hill no representative
Dee no representative foot no
representative C no representative Coker
no representative
Sykes yes representative Rich yes
representative Sinclair yes
representative rung yes representative
Rambo yes representative AO yes
representative NAB yes representative
blondon yes representative collabro yes
representative Johnson yes and chairman
Walsh no 10 to
nine motion of inexpedient our
recommendation of inexpedient to legisl
is adopted 1029 I'll close the executive
session on Senate Bill
538 don't panic
uh we're not we're not close yet um hold
on one second for me to ask a
question
e e
okay um getting back to the motion that
we had previously let's start over chair
recognizes representative SES for a
motion thank you Mr chairman I make a
motion to reconsider house bill
501 a Senate Bill house uh five Senate
Bill
501 um reconsideration has been moved is
there second representative
Vu did you care to speak to your
motion very briefly Mr chairman thank
you um I brought this motion forward
because it became clear to me and uh
that one of the members uh
uh made an error in their vote and would
like the opportunity to reconsider that
vote and so this is the proper format
and methodology that we have available
to us in order to do
that I'll just say this as you know I
probably know what the outcome of this
is going to be but that doesn't matter
what does matter is what I mentioned
before that we have a tradition in of
getting along in this committee and I
want that to continue but more
importantly I also have a great amount
of respect for representative Rich who I
believe we have served together for 10
years now and if she tells me she made a
mistake then I'm going to Grant the
reconsideration which I already have in
in essence uh but we'll also support
it uh anybody else from the committee
seeing none unless the clerk to call the
world motion is reconsideration on
Senate Bill
501 Vice chairman
Gorski yes representative Smith
yes clerk votes yes representative Hill
yep representative
de representative foot yes
representative C yes representative
Coker yes representative
Sykes yes representative Rich yes
representative Sinclair yes
representative rang yes representative
Rambo yes representative ve yes
representative NAB yes representative
pund yes representative Cabra yes
representative Johnson yes and chairman
Walsh yes 19 to
Z all right well actually let me give
the clerk a
minute okay
uh Senate Bill 501 uh reconsideration
has been adopted I'll open up the
executive session on 501 and bear with
me I haven't gone through this process
but I think I'm taking the right steps
is there a motion on Senate Bill
501 oh actually no we have
to yes all right so the motion on the
floor is inexpedient to
legislate and with the reconsideration
we'll we'll vote on that again I'll ask
the clerk to call the role when she is
ready it
correct Vice chairman Gorski yes
representative Smith yes clerk votes yes
representative Hill yes representative
Dee yes representative foot yes
representative C yes representative
Coker yes represent
Sykes no representative
Rich representative Sinclair no
representative rang no representative
Rambo no representative Ao No
representative NAB no Representative
pandon no representative Calabro no
representative Johnson no and chairman
Walsh can hear you representative sakes
uh yes
nine to 10 try to avoid any further
errors um so the motion of any expedient
legislate surprisingly enough fails is
there a
motion repr you've already made
one okay representative
Sykes thank you Mr chairman I move ought
to
pass um motion is ought to pass on CER
bill 51 is there second represent
seconded by representative cabro uh any
further discussion representative
Sykes thank you no Mr chairman I think
we've uh heard a lot about this anybody
else from the committee seeing none I'll
ask the clerk to call the role the
motion is ought to pass on Senate Bill
501 Vice chairman mski
no representative Smith no clerk votes
no representative Hill no representative
de no representative foot no
representative C no representative sers
oops sorry Representative hoker no
representative
Sykes yes representative BR
representative Sinclair yes
representative rang yes representative
Rambo yes representative AO yes
representative AB yes representative
pandon yes representative cabro yes
representative Johnson yes and chairman
Walsh
no 10 to nine committee's recommendation
about the pass is adop the 10 nine I'll
close the executive session on Senate
Bill
again uh hold on a second um let me talk
with our ranking member for a
moment e
um that will conclude our business that
will conclude the bills that we've had
for this year and for both years
actually I just want to thank everybody
from the committee it's been a
pleasure and anybody else for the good
of the con
representative SES thank you Mr chairman
um I just wanted to thank everybody as
well um today was a little bit of a h
slog but I think that um I'm
appreciative particularly of my
colleagues in the committee who voted
overwhelmingly for reconsideration that
was uh much appreciated and noted
representative Hill thank you Mr
chairman I think the committee is lucky
to have had a chairman that would be
willing to do the things that he did um
I also think that uh we owe thanks to
our clerk who uh has kept us on an even
Keel through the whole
thing as well
as as well as our researcher and uh
committee assistant you you stole my
thunder but
absolutely one more second uh one more
order business we have two Senate
messages and I have them here I just
want to review those while we are in
executive session um to before so I can
submit them uh and decide whether we're
going to concur or non-c concur just
give me a couple
minutes e
Mr chairman may
I yep representative Smith thank you so
for years this committee was fortunate
to have Superstar committee researchers
we had Nancy lavenus back in the day and
then Gen 4 who is extremely qualified
diligent I I had a big problem with Jen
when I'd have a question top of mine so
I send an email off I don't know on a
Saturday and she answers me on a
Saturday night I'm like please stop
working okay have a life but she was
great so we were spoiled that way and
then we got a new committee researcher
and I will tell you what he doesn't want
me to tell you he was prepared to hate
you after all of that and it's like
great we get the new guy I don't have
time for that and it was very quickly
that he was coming to me is speaking
very highly of you thank you for
everything that you do and you have
earned your spot we appreciate you
speaking of our committee researcher
looking I was looking for the side by
side on the sended message for House
Bill 1550 I'm just teasing
okay while we're waiting we're looking
into just one change that the Senate uh
made on House Bill 1550 but we'll do
this one just for a consensus of the
committee House Bill 12
11:22 which was the bill that we passed
relative to lights on motor vehicles uh
the Senate just made one change uh just
for clarity and I believe this came from
the Department's recommendations the
safety that is the provisions of this
section shall not apply to a vehicle
with original equipment manufacturer OEM
front Lighting systems or a front
lighting system of a similar type
installed as standard equipment by the
Vehicle Manufacturer so in other words
it's just a a general blanket that if it
comes from the factory it's good um so
any objection to concurring with their
change all right so that's what we'll do
on that one and there's one minor change
they made to the seasonal speed limit
Bill too we're just trying to identify
exactly what word was added uh I believe
will be on the same in the same
direction but just give me one
second and yes I should have done this
before we got here today
okay we found it
they added one word to the bill just for
clarity the
original the original Bill mentioned
um reasonable and safe conditions upon a
part of a highway system that a
municipality seasonally
congested and the amendment reasonable
and safe conditions upon any part of a
municipal highway system that is
seasonally congested sounds like just a
grammar change in adding the word
municip
I'm fine with it any objections for
concurrence seeing none that's what
we'll do all right that's it uh if
there's nothing else for Jour all right
thank
you and reports I do need before people
leave today I've got some of them
coming and before before you leave we'll
look at a debate sheet too so we can get
everything out of the way
today
okay e